yeah well any company that is based in
china the the
the government can just go in and take
okay this this company is ours now
period done so this is the executive
order
it came out just the other day the
president's executive order on hong kong
normalization
by the authority vested in me as
president by the constitution and laws
of the united states of america
including the united states hong kong
policy act of 1992
the hong kong human rights and democracy
act of 2019
the hong kong autonomy act of 2020
signed into law july 14th
2020 the international emergency
economic powers act
the national emergencies act the uh what
it was
of national emergencies act section of
the immigration immigration and
nationality act of 1952
and section 301 of title 3 united states
code i donald trump hereby enact yadda
yadda
so the well there's a lot i'm going to
read his opening statement because it's
not very long but it's going to give you
the important context yeah
he writes i donald trump president of
the united states of america determined
pursuant to section 202
of the united states hong kong policy
act of 1992 that the special
administrative region of hong kong is no
longer sufficiently autonomous
to justify differential treatment in
relations to the people's republic of
china
under that under the particular united
states laws and provisions thereof set
out in this order
in late may 2020 the national people's
congress of china announced its
intention to unilaterally
and arbitrarily impose national security
legislation on hong kong
this announcement was merely china's
latest salvo in a series of actions
that have increasingly denied autonomy
and freedoms that china promised to the
people of hong kong under the 1984
joint declaration of government of the
united kingdom of great britain
and northern ireland and the government
of the people's republic of china
on the question of hong kong as a result
on may 27 2020 the secretary of state
announced
that the prc had fundamentally
undermined hong kong's autonomy
and certified and reported to the
congress pursuant to sections 205 and
301
of the united states hong kong policy
act of 1992 as amended respectively
that hong kong no longer warrants
treatment under united states law
in the same manner as united states laws
were applied to hong kong before july 1
1997.
on may 29 2020 i directed the heads of
executive departments and agencies
to begin the process of eliminating
policy exemptions under united's law
that give hong kong differential
treatment
in relation to china he goes on to say
china has since followed through on its
threat to impose national security
legislation
they explain you know there's no right
to trial by jury proceedings may be
conducted in secret
china has given itself broad power to
initiate and control the prosecutions of
people of hong kong
through the new office of safeguarding
national security at the same time the
laws allow foreigners to be expelled
if china merely suspects them of
violating the law potentially making it
harder for journalists
human rights organizations and other
outside groups to hold the prc
accountable for its treatment of the
people of hong kong
i therefore determine that the situation
with respect to hong kong including
recent actions taken by the prc to
fundamentally undermine hong kong's
autonomy
constitutes an unusual and extraordinary
threat which has its source in
substantial part outside the us
to the national security foreign policy
and economy of the united states
i hereby declare a national emergency
with respect to that threat
now the important sections i can't read
through everything is section four
all property and interests in property
that are in the united states
that here after come within the united
states or that
are or that are or hereafter come within
the possession or control of any
united states person or the following
persons are blocked
and may not be transferred paid exported
withdrawn or otherwise dealt
in that means an american citizen
who has say assets and maybe tick tock
that means these companies
trump's going to be like blocked assets
gone
i mean this is extreme this is serious
yes whether it's the right thing sorry
if that was loud but
whether it's needed to happen this is
important right here
this is serious that's why i read that
and i was like
[Music]
if you're working for china you're
you're in trouble and this means
period this means these these professors
yep
exactly agencies that do uh student
visas
this is just cut off basically
everything
and this was yesterday so the
implications of today
twitter being cyber a cyber a major
major cyber against a former president
and the current president
a contender for the president exactly
serious man
i think it's i think it's war man yep
and and you know
i've talked about it too i've done
several segments that we're on the brink
of war with china
that we've had you know they've lasered
our planes
you know that's basically like letting
them know that we can target you they've
sent
uh you know their strike group through
the south china sea they're trying to
take over
uh some indian land they're fighting
with india they're they're
there's there's reports of them taking
land from
almost every uh neighboring country
around them yeah
you got the you got the concentration
camps yep i saw a video today of them
moving a lot of uh
a lot of them it was a it was a terrible
video but
i got to say it this is china china is
is our generation in nazi germany
not an exaggeration in the least bit
they're expanding they're seizing land
they say is
is historically theirs they're locking
people in concentration camps harvesting
their organs to be sold
they've stolen our manufacturing base
they control too much of what
of what we need and now they're going to
start repressing hong kong
and this is they have have been they
literally are doing it yeah the people
of hong kong are used to
you know like english english common law
as a former british i believe was a
colony of
the uk of britain and it's being
transferred to china and now they're
starting to
suppress their rights yep people have
been asking what are we going to do are
we going to do something well the law
gives trump the power to do so check
this out
he says uh what does it says or the
following persons any foreign person
determined
by the secretary of state in
consultation with the secretary of
treasury or the secretary
of the treasury in consultation with the
secretary of state
to be or have been involved directly or
indirectly look at that
wow in the coercing arresting detaining
or imprisoning of individual individuals
under the authority of
or to be or have been responsible for or
involved in developing adopting
implementing the law of the people's
republic of china
on safeguarding national security in the
hong kong administrative region
excuse me to be responsible for or
complicit
in or to have engaged in directly or
indirectly any of the following
actions or policies that undermine
democratic processes or institutions in
hong kong
actions or policies that threaten the
peace security stability or autonomy of
hong kong
censorship or other activities with
respect to hong kong that prohibit
prohibit
limit or penalize the exercise of
freedom of expression or assembly by
citizens of hong kong
or that lemon act limit access to free
and independent print online or
broadcast media or
the extra judicial rendition arbitrary
detention
or torture of any person in hong kong or
other gross violations of
internationally recognized human rights
or serious human rights abuses in hong
kong to be
or have been the leader of he goes on
but i want to point this out
indirectly yeah indirectly
china is is communist yep they use
market economics to their advantage to
grow
but chinese officials are you know at
every level of these companies these
purchases the investments
these foreign maneuvers that's tick-tock
he's talking about tick-tock
that's that's an indirect attack that
they're they're
stealing american data indirectly china
has access to that
if it's if it's a chinese company
okay about whether or not okay you are
indirectly in some way hurting hong kong
that's that's i'm sure if they're doing
it to america it's already enough for
trump to take some of these
good point good point so to have
material
materially assisted sponsored provided
financial material or technological
support for
there it is if a chinese official
uses tick tock yep that's it
this is extremely broad this gives trump
insane
power i guess the us government he says
section five i hereby determine that the
making of donations of the types of
articles specified in section 203
buy to or for the benefit of any person
whose property and interests in property
are blocked pursuant to second four of
this order
would seriously impair my ability to
deal with the national emergency
declared in this order
and i hereby prohibit such donations as
provided by section four of this order
even more broad wow you can't give money
nope to somebody who maybe is indirectly
providing technological support
to somebody this is wow this is
seven degrees of separation almost so
was it a coincidence then that
we see this major cyber attack in the
u.s not at all it was the first thing
that popped in my head
like yep the executive order now you're
telling me we twitter just got slammed
it's like yeah that makes total sense
let me know if you see blue checks
coming back onto twitter i will keep an
eye on it
because this is this has been going on
for a long time it's been a few hours
now
in a few hours i'm going to uh
i'm going to start a garden garden
you're out okay get out get out of the
zone i'm out
you mean sign off the twitter no i can't
i have to check the twitter zone
the test twitter zone yeah yeah yeah but
yeah we're gonna we're gonna start a uh
a taz garden
no it's gonna be a chat it's gonna be
digital i don't see anything a digital
garden if you will yes
we're gonna grow digital roses that
we're going to smell
they're going to smell great and the
best yes the best
the best digital roses you've ever
smelled frankly i've never actually
smelled a digital rose
oh that's good yeah so what are you are
you checking to see if you can uh
see anything i got sent something from a
high profile individual talking about a
leaked admin control panel but i don't
know if it's real so i'm just trying to
i'd be very careful about right being
sent anything on twitter right now
yeah yeah so right now i'm hearing that
it's not just blue check marks
like we heard with with uh with you
lydia you couldn't tweet i can do it for
a while a bunch of people were blocked
out as well
i don't know i don't know how they did
it what their what their decision was
but um maybe it's time to nationalize
twitter
yeah maybe so will will chamberlain of
human events has been
um i don't know i don't think he's a
proponent of nationalizing but he's
saying it now
but he has been a proponent of social
media access being a human right
and i think you know what i want to do i
want to pull up uh i believe i'm trying
josh hawley's letter
yes josh hawley has been talking about
issues of social media free speech and
censorship
and has apparent according to saurabh
sharma ramblings in the daily caller now
i got i got to tell you
nobody's verified right i don't know if
anybody is that's a good point
we're after we have to rely on but i've
seen this be this going around and it
looks legit
he says inbox senator hawley mo just
sent this letter to twitter ceo jack per
the security breaches today
the letter reads dear mr dorsey as i
write twitter seems to be experiencing a
large-scale cyber attack as illustrated
by a number
of posts inviting users to transfer
bitcoin under fraudulent pretenses
the accounts targeted include those for
apple uber
jeff bezos former president barack obama
and even the democratic nominee for
president
the list of affected accounts is growing
by the minute some affected accounts are
alleged to have been protected by
twitter's two-factor authentication
that is crazy yeah it is yeah washington
post verifies that holly sent this
okay yeah he says i am concerned that
this event may represent not merely a
coordinated set of separate hacking
incidents but rather a successful attack
on the security of twitter itself
as you know millions of your users rely
on your service
not just to tweet publicly but also to
communicate privately through your
direct message service
a successful attack on your system
servers represents a threat to all
of your users privacy and data security
please reach out
immediately to the department of justice
and the federal bureau of investigation
and take any necessary measures to
secure this site secure the site
before this breach expands once you have
a attended to immediate concerns please
respond to the following questions
did this event represent a breach of
users account security or of twitter
systems
were accounts protected by two-factor
authentication successfully targeted in
this breach if so how is this possible
did this breach compromise the account
security of users whose accounts were
not used to share fraudulent posts
if so how many accounts were affected
were all account security compromised by
this breach
how many users may have faced data theft
as a consequence of this breach
what measures does twitter undertake to
prevent system level hacks
from breaching the security of its
entire user base did this attack
threaten the security of the president's
own
twitter account sincerely josh hawley i
want to know the answers
me too yeah we need to know how did they
bypass two factor i know i know
several ways now listen i
my immediate reaction when i saw this
was state level attack yeah cyber war
and all that stuff
because i know people and i've known a
lot of people and i've interviewed
several people
who could snap their fingers and pull
off things like this this this seems
like a sophisticated intelligence agency
attack the fact that we're still under
this lockdown on twitter can't get a
hold of things
i can't stress enough how absolutely
insane that is it is
it sounds like jack dorsey himself has
been locked out of his own company
yup oh my gosh what do you do shut it
down
they did you know they shut it down to
the extent they can but what would
happen if these these hackers
literally over time removed
the administrator's ability think about
it
when you're developing twitter that's a
good point you you can put all these
codes in place
what would happen if a state-level actor
over the span of a year
was writing code and adding it to their
code base so that they could have
a kill switch yeah that they press the
button and then every single employee of
twitter was locked out and twitter is
now
controlled completely wow true
autonomous zone how would you
how would they deal with that i'm
talking like state level serious
you got that you got that you get you
got that button wow how dare you button
it's all i have now i'm going to see
what's up
so i i was able to inadvertent i was
able to bypass the the objections this
is this is huge
i allowed it to happen will came to me
and he said
warlord adam is this okay that i passed
this on and i said
yes it's okay you can post it
i am verified on twitter i tried to
tweet
and it wouldn't let me and this is what
it said so i asked will chamberlain of
human events to tweet it because
will james spear the editor-in-chief of
human events
uh can't he's not verified and he said
hey tim cass wants me to tweet something
and i'm saying let me in let me in but
this is what i see when i try and tweet
something went wrong but don't fret
let's give it another shot no let's not
it didn't work
so will ever so uh uh humorously
changed his name from chamberlain to
james doing this a lot because he's
declaring the proletariat twitter
unverified revolution
and that's basically what's going on on
twitter right now for those that are not
familiar
um all of the unverified people are are
laughing
blue checks is trending blue checks this
is trending
and lots of memes so many memes
so i want to see if uh let me see
kevin roose is retweeted by will
chamberlain if whoever apparently has
read write access to every verified
twitter account also has access to those
accounts dms
this could make the sony hack look tiny
oh i remember that
could you imagine what would happen if
the direct messages
of journalists got released i mean they
obviously have access to it
they have access to broadcast they might
have been
downloading everything joe biden's
directing and it's too late it's too
late they already had it if they were
tweeting out they had they could see it
and they were probably
and maybe man and the fallout's gonna be
insane maybe it's not so much a shot
across the bow
as a you know it's it's it's captain
jack
riding away in the interceptor waving
goodbye this
this this fake bitcoin thing was them
saying we exfiltrated your data yeah
have a nice day
yeah we got what we needed and then what
did you keep talking about bitcoin
and they scuttled the ship on the way
out yep so now jack's like what happened
how do we fix this we don't know
yeah and you can't they got the
information no no i mean
jack can't even gain control of twitter
i say jack but like people at twitter
right now they've there's no control
they can't they can't stop these hacks
they can't blue checks are shut down
completely
wow you you know the scene i'm talking
about in parts of the caribbean yeah
yeah i'm gonna explain this the first
movie right the first one yeah
yeah so jack and and will two characters
want to steal this ship
but you can't crew a ship with only two
people so he goes on to
i forget which ship it's you know and
the dauntless i think
and then he starts trying to pull the
sails down and the
the you know royal guard see him and
they laugh so they take
the interceptor which they have used a
whole crew to set everything up
come over to board that ship and get him
off and then he jumps to their ship and
takes off with it
and then he turns on and waves goodbye
and when they try to catch him
their ship has been scuttled the rudder
has been their chain's been broken yeah
so this is maybe that's what it is they
got in they got the data
and then they busted it up and then said
bitcoin bitcoin bitcoin
yep everyone would know they did it
but more importantly national security
trump the feds the doj
are right now going what did they get
yep what did they get and jack dorsey is
probably sweating bullets
i would be if i was in his seat could
you imagine
but i'm not i'm sitting on my new my new
twitter throne what do you think would
happen
if if all of the dms of every blue check
journalist just got dropped
oh my i'd i'd uh get my reading glasses
on that would be a civil war in two
seconds
i would two seconds you know i made my
throne out of blue checks too
blue checks bluetooth i seized them from
the businesses i took them all and just
made a big throne out of it winning blue
checks in the guillotine that's great
nice
no but i'm not kidding i mean there
there are stories right covington for
instance
imagine when you get access to the dms
of these journalists who are lying
and you find out some of them light on
purpose yeah what happens who's telling
them to lie
yep and yeah the real truth of
everything
yeah yeah i want to read them all yeah i
can't i can't wait almost the united
states
the u.s would be ripped apart in two
seconds it's true no not to be
quite frightening i think that actually
might um
that that might strengthen the us in a
dangerous way
how so if we saw that the entire news
industry was corrupt and these people
behind the scenes were lying on purpose
yep
then they would be completely
disregarded the entire argument of the
left would be
gone yep and trump would be saying i
told you they were fake news yep and
then what would happen
trump loyalists the military everybody
would say whatever you say trump yep
because we can't trust those people
just totally destroy whatever
credibility they had you're going to see
conversations between antifa far
leftists violent
you know criminals and terrorists and
journalists laughing together
you're going to hear you're going to see
conversations because i know these exist
where journalists is jokingly talking to
somebody about grabbing a drink and
and then them saying hey i got a big
story check it out this guy did this
thing cool cool
yeah yeah feed me all that stuff yeah
you're going to see journalists saying
anything i can amplify
you got any you got any actions coming
up that i can i can i can publish so
that people show up
or let's let's spread this this specific
story so no one knows about
what the real workings of what's
happening right over over here
let's just blow this story out of
proportion ivanka held up a goya can
oh my gosh let's spread it everywhere
meanwhile
everything is happening i'm talking
about sources though yeah yeah yeah
definitely the journalists talking to
themselves
that'll be interesting stuff you're
going to see them being like which story
are you covering
if it was the activists though you're
gonna see journalists being like keep up
the good work guys
that was really great and they're gonna
be like did you see that we bashed that
guy's head and ha ha yeah i did
you're gonna see that from journalists
probably i've dude i've i've uh been
privy to some of the conversations these
people have and i'll tell you
some of the stuff i won't bring up
because it will compromise sources and
ongoing you know news and investigations
but
yeah you'd be surprised what the far
left you know
what what these what these activists do
how far they're willing to go
and how nasty they can be who they're
communicating with
i got to be very vague on this but there
are there are certain individuals
who no i can't i can't i can't i don't
want to compromise an ongoing
investigation because
there could be some big stories in the
stuff that i know but just put this way
there's some evil evil people
it looks like the blue checks are back
blue checks are back no
it looks like uh i i ted cruz is posting
oh yeah everyone's back
thomas massey's back okay yeah
everyone's returned seems seems like so
is the teacher's healing it's opened up
a little bit
is there is are there any updates are we
seeing anything from like did ted cruz
address it or is anything going on no he
just did uh
these look like jumping up i mean it's
from 40 seconds ago
okay so it looks like maybe they were
backlogged i don't know
were they backlogged i don't know so i'm
trying to okay dave says dave rubin says
hello
hello dave yeah welcome back the tweets
i tried putting out aren't out so
okay i refuse to relinquish control okay
understand not happening sorry sorry
twitter
everyone's back well the garden the
garden will be assembled that's right
i need those roses well the the the good
news is that it wasn't until
uh the chassis stannis showed up to
mayor durkin's house
oh right that she actually shut him down
so i think you'll be okay so long as you
don't actually tweet at jack as soon as
i told him i made a
throne out of blue checks they were like
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa too far
too far no no just don't treat a jack
you do the jack and then he's like
send them in yeah send in the feds
so civil war war with china
yeah man it's got to be china we've been
talking about this
for months both right
so i think who who who which one of you
said it you were like so does this
replace the civil war then
replay and that is like this world war
or civil war would yeah
and we we did talk about before on this
show that
the only thing that would probably stop
a civil war is a common enemy a common
threat
in china yep yeah and then people would
be like
overnight i don't care about whatever
that was yep because
what yeah exactly china china's
operating concentration camps man what
do we do
i know it's messed up how are people not
freaking out about that
we can't call we can't fall victim to
any of the classic blunders least of all
is never get into a land war in asia
that's right oh we can't do that
yeah wow you're not kidding except now
i'm really taking it seriously
i don't know that specifically
references though from princess bread i
don't know
like napoleon seems wise i don't know
yeah
yeah so i guess that's it i guess the
blue checks are back that was a really
long cyborg how long was that how long
it was like two hours when did i get hit
no two and a half hours yeah maybe three
yeah almost three hours right on holy
moly
yeah i want i want to know the answers
to those questions
to jack from uh who who wrote those who
wrote that letter josh hawley
josh hawley yeah i wanna i wanna know
the answers jack do we nationalize
you we we all as americans deserve to
know
how far we were compromised because we
use your service
and it's on you yes and your employees i
think we have no choice right now
but we need some kind of nationalization
of twitter
yeah yeah so josh hawley is kind of one
of my heroes because he's been calling
for an audit
an internal audit on twitter since like
april
well now it seems like they won't have a
choice in their choice anymore yeah so
they have to all right like you you have
to be audited now
like we need to know what happened
that's a great question
who you know did someone leak you know
the password
the the the uh the entrance key
the back door no this is more than that
man i know yeah but this is this is not
about an audit this is about
if they're in now we don't need to audit
we need
to
we've mentioned it if someone takes the
they did they took these accounts
they could have tweeted something way
worse you're absolutely right the
bitcoin thing i think netted 100
100 grand or something oh did they they
they got a bunch of money that's what
people are saying yeah it reached like
100 grand
that's not but it doesn't seem like
worth it on this kind of a scale
certainly certainly which is right i
think so i think it's
short sale tesla yep and have musk tweet
out something about his passing and then
yeah boom you're rich yeah he could have
done they could have done so much more
damage
and harder to trace hey it's like but
heart listen listen i mean it's it's
sure it sounds like a lot of money but
no listen it is not in the scheme of
things they can't use these bitcoins
these bitcoins are on a public ledger
they can track where they're going yeah
yeah
if they did the short sale scam you
wouldn't know who
who you know who was shorting tesla
that's true was the person who did the
hack
and that person would make the money
they could spend it so this was not that
yep
so right now the conversation is do we
nationalize twitter there's a lot of
reasons for one
it's a complete uh it's it's 10 steps
above
section 230 reform you'd have first
amendment protections if that were the
case yep
u.s cyber command and whatever else you
know officials come in
and they start reinforcing our
communications grid our social media
technology
i think it needs to happen could you um
could you imagine if say in like world
war ii
we lost the ability to communicate
that'd be crazy
we we would have lost if we couldn't
communicate with
around the world and coordinate our
attacks like there's
there's i mean i've i've seen lots of
documentaries about world war ii about
the
amount of stuff that that had that they
did in that war and it's it's incredible
the communication era yeah if we didn't
have it who knows how long it would have
taken
right and if we would have won this is
what i've been saying for a long time
it's really scary yeah that these social
media companies are slowly replacing the
commons
we used to have public debates at you
know the town hall meetings right at
church
at the work water cooler now it's all
social media
and you've got private big brother
looking over thanks for checking out
this clip from the tim cast irl podcast
we do the show
live monday through friday at 8pm if you
want to catch the full show
tune in to this channel subscribe hit
the like button or
check us out on itunes and spotify and
we will soon have this podcast up for
free
on all podcast platforms thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all in the
next episode
you